He de decirle,
aunque usted hoy no tiene ganas de debates,
qué VA a responder usted
tarde o temprano
por cada 1 de los cheques sin fondos
que ha entregado a los enemigos de España
para permanecer
en el poder. Usted pasará a la historia.
Es lo que quiere, sin ninguna duda.
Pero pasará la historia por tratar de deslegitimar
a nuestros tribunales,
a nuestras leyes,
a nuestras fuerzas y cuerpos de seguridad del estado.
Creo que fue usted el que
después del golpe separatista de 2 017,
acudió a 1 hospital a visitar a alguno de los policías
gravemente heridos
por los golpistas.
¿Iría ahora de Nuevo a visitarle?
Iría a decir a esos policías
que según usted, esas heridas son fruto
de 1 conflicto político
y que sus agresores deben ser amnistiados.
Ninguna de sus maquinaciones nos resulta ya
ni novedosa ni desconocida,
aunque muchos antes que usted Han intentado retorcer
las leyes a su antojo.
Yo creo que hay que reconocerle a usted
que nadie ha llegado a Tal límite de desvergüenza.
En eso hay que reconocer que usted tiene
1 gigantesco liderazgo.
También es líder en violaciones, señor Sánchez.
Bajo su gobierno,
España ha batido el récord de ese crimen abyecto.
Nunca en España
se habían producido tantas agresiones a mujeres
y ya sabemos lo que hizo usted
al respecto durante los 4 años de gobierno,
soltar violadores a la calle.
Este año, por lo tanto,
volverá usted a batir su propio récord y lo sufrirán.
Y Lo le reconozco que me produce
1 rabia inmensa.
Mujeres inocentes.
Le deseo que algún día se encuentre usted
Cara a Cara con ellas,
con sus maridos,
con sus padres o con sus hijos.
También es el líder de la ruina
España. En 2 022 está a la cabeza de las grandes
de las grandes economías
en reducción de salarios reales,
es decir, a la cabeza en rebajar sueldos.
Eso lo ha conseguido usted
Gracias a 1 numeroso equipo que conforma
el gobierno más caro de la historia de España